yeah dude i always when that song came
out i was not in any sort of christian
frame of mind
and i remember looking at that going
man that's demonic like like and i
wasn't even like close to
out of the top 100 songs on the radio
who wrote the majority of the music
find out on this episode of led live
[Music]
light exposing darkness
welcome to led live we're going to talk
about some very interesting stuff today
but before we do i want to say thank you
to our patreons that are
supporting us because we couldn't do
without you but today we're going to
talk about music and we don't really
talk much about that on this channel but
there's some fascinating stuff that's
happening in the music field and i think
the most important thing is that we we
cover this topic because
there's some really interesting stuff
did you know
that the uh majority of the songs in the
pop realm were made in the last 20 30
years even well made by one man that's
crazy that is what do you mean by like
what do you mean by like the majority
what do you mean so so uh the majority
as in uh a significant portion of the
individual artists that have created use
one man to do to do a their lyrics and
to do their music so like ghostwriter
yeah so it goes right they go to this
guy and say hey i don't have i don't
have a song but i can sing really well
uh can you can you help me and he's like
uh yeah i'll write this
or sing this and do this and and you
should you'll be amazed in fact we're
going to find out he has
he even though he's not well known he
has the majority
of the top number one hits wow and
probably never sung a song and i was
like i don't know it's like i have heard
that a lot of artists don't write their
own music like britney spears and stuff
in sync and stuff when they come out
uh because i don't know i think they're
kind of just molded like if you want to
be big you have to sound like this and
then once you get your legs then we'll
let you write your own stuff but i
didn't know that they were a lot of them
were written by one single person yeah i
i think like lady gaga was a writer for
other people before she actually became
on her own in fact uh i think isn't it
sean puffy combs was the same way i
think he wrote rhymes and wraps and
stuff like that and then was giving them
to him so is that his name yeah i don't
know it's puffy i don't know what he
goes by now but that's the distinction
you have entertainers and you have
artists yeah artists are the ones
actually creating the music the
entertainers sing it they're the face
the personality right yeah just because
you can write the music i guess you
wouldn't be a good front man that's not
always the case so i guess i've ever
heard of this was millie vanilla
there were like two models that couldn't
sing and so the actual what you heard on
the album was just these
older people that weren't
didn't look the best for the the the
image or whatever but millie vanilli
were the image these
like twins or something like brothers
that were hot models or whatever they
had been the end of endless like you
know videos and jokes about it and like
the music would cut off and they'd still
be dancing
the record was skipped at the live or
that happened before the record skipped
and they're right and they're just like
uh one guy ran off stage
this is different because these guys
aren't they're not mimicking someone
else's song as in lip syncing yeah
they're actually taking someone else's
words someone else's uh produce music
and saying hey now this is my own i'm
gonna cut they're basically covering
this guy's material wow and and he
doesn't even want full credit that's
what's going to ask that he's not
credited on the side a little bit yeah
he's like he's like in the credits on
the very bottom of you know of the song
song written by uh britney spears and uh
this guy you know but then again it's
like how much is that really worth if
he's getting paid and if he's in a
position of control or power i guess he
doesn't care that his name isn't and he
can actually go grocery shopping without
being bombarded by people
right yeah so do you want to know who
this is yes this is fascinating so first
i'm going to show you all these
different actors and they're going to
say
thank you so much to this guy actors
excuse me okay uh the the musicians and
they're going to say thank you to this
guy working with max in the studio for
me is very relaxed working with max is
a lot of laughter working with max
martin is awesome because he is such a
huge
fan of music and he's such like a um he
has a really infectious energy max is
great in the studio he's he's a
perfectionist which i totally respect
he has a childlike quality
to his
melody sensibilities i can't
describe the impact max has made on the
music scene over the years he's done
nothing but
make the most amazing music i think
of all time of our generation of
generations to come
at the time when i first worked with max
and was brittany and backstreet boys it
was just like
those songs were one after the other
after the other after the other and you
could still go back and listen to them
and they're just great songs
i don't think max is human
i think max was made in sweden
to make hit records because nobody
human can do what he's done over the
years it is literally unbelievable
his sound was always
transcending you know it was always
ahead of the game
i think that max's secret is probably
something along the lines of
the simplest
[Music]
most effective thing is always the best
stop
take a deep breath
[Music]
simplify
he's he's really good at i mean
a great chef says the most important
ingredient is the thing you leave out
and i think that's also great for
producing that that's what he brings is
he he sort of
takes all of you and then goes
these parts are fantastic let's work
with this
he
helped to shape a sound and define the
sound
and that's what makes him a genius his
melodies
are so incredible and so
sophisticated but simple it's funny when
you hear music on the radio and you hear
a certain yow
you automatically think it's max even if
it's not people emulate him people want
to be like him and want to have that max
martin sound he's the most obsessed with
music and that's it but he's a lot of
fun to work with he's an amazing person
and i'm very very talented you've got to
love the music that's what's important
and he loves pop music i mean he just
he's he amazes me and i really got a
chance to get to know him and you just
fall in love with him really easily you
are a master
take us to the promised land
i mean why why why
no what's interesting is somebody said
he's not it's like he's not even human
everything he writes is a masterpiece
and then he's like take us to the
promised land bowing to him like
that's kind of telling you have all
three elements
love the music or love what you do keep
it simple and there's also that spirit
the supernatural power as well
they said it their words right yeah yeah
it's not human take us to the promised
land yeah it's like you're influencing
generations of people with the music and
i think they know it i think that's a
telltale sign of like you know
how much they're aware of that fact yeah
yeah now i want to show exactly uh what
how many songs this guy makes because
when we hear songs on the radio and
typically i try not to i if i go to the
grocery store i go to the gym
it's inevitable it's going to happen and
i get these songs that are stuck in my
head and they're they're called ear
worms right yeah and um but
you let me just go over some of the
songs real quick this is just from
britney spears if you know anything
about britney spears uh baby one more
time crazy i will be there oops i did it
again can't make you love me don't go
knocking on my door lucky stronger
britain brittany overprotected bombastic
love cinderella i'm not a girl yet a
woman when you are where you are now
female fairy tale
fairy tale yeah hold it against me till
the world ends i go inside out i mean it
just goes on and on
these are all songs that max wrote for
her for her wow this is just her and
actually written annie
that's more than an album right there oh
yeah it's like
can you imagine being one person and
being like you hear yourself on the
radio yeah that was me and then the next
song oh yeah that's me too the next song
he asked me like no band could ever do
that because they're not gonna play one
band after another on the radio they're
gonna make sure they mix it up but if
you wrote songs for different bands
you could hear your song the whole day
really right throughout this time that
he's been doing this he's had songs on
the radio that are in the top 10
sometimes five of them at a time
wow five out of the ten were his song
which doesn't happen like if you're
nicki minaj you don't have five songs at
the top yeah because you're one
yeah musician
but that's that's interesting because
you know nicki minaj she has a character
she has uh
and her style so to speak so but with
him writing for all these different
people that's five different styles five
different personalities five different
genres maybe how does he cause that
because those songs are sort of crafted
for her right right so they're like
she's probably doing that promoting her
character like you know yeah so not only
is he writing uh songs love songs about
boys but he's also writing love songs
about girls as well he has uh
or does he have the ability to write for
all different types of genres and think
in the terms that they would be able to
do this is it him
or could it be something else that's
happening that's interesting so so let's
let's go into this a little bit deeper
i'm going to show you some of the
different artists he's worked with
check this out composer in the world has
written melodies as sustainable or as
widespread as those of max martin he has
refined and developed the world's
popular music he is the producer with
the most number one singles max martin
has written 23 to 25 there are some
different things statistics online
number one singles that's not just
singles he's written that's number one
singles that have hit the top of the
chart can't go any higher than this he's
written 23 to 25 of those he's best
known to work with you ready for this
these these the people that he works
with
katy perry britney spears kelly clarkson
pinks taylor swift ariana grande maroon
5 coldplay avril lavigne usher lady gaga
kesha delene celine dion christina
aguilera simple plan uh jennifer lopez
demi lovato justin timberlake adele bon
jovi uh ellie
goulding
tori uh kelly and the weeknd and those
are only ones i recognize so i do have
to i have to ask this question because
i'm working on this video about dj
khaled and just looking into what he
does i wasn't of the opinion that he was
a producer but really what he's more of
is a promoter or marketer he gets all
the people in the room he gets people to
make the beats he gets people to write
the songs and all that and gets the
talent puts it all together and puts out
a project with his name on it so i'm
wondering
with max martin writing these songs
getting number one
is it the lyrics itself that are pushing
it to number one or is it a mixture but
more like the talent that's getting its
number one let me write a song for
ariana grande she's like at her peak
right now let me give her this song it's
going to be number one and that could be
part of my catalogue you think that has
a role to play or this is
mainly like people are praising the
lyricism in the songs yeah that is an
interesting question and i guess like
one
one that i want to answer or ask as well
is like is as just because you wrote the
song that's not the least that's not the
tune right right but yeah like dj
khaled's praise like we're the best
music i'm number one well
you
you're playing off of all these yeah
there's like a-listers and of course
you're going to be number one if
everyone likes you know the character
here i mean the the person that you're
collaborating with well we're actually
going to answer this question i think a
little bit for uh just the next slide
here okay it's it's uh it's pretty
telling because he's
even though he's helping out in a much
bigger studio um he is also writing
a majority of these things
but it's interesting that he is
not the top
artist that has written something the
only two people that are above him
you ready for this
we know a little bit about this not
michael john lennon is that the boom
so it's paul mccartney and john lennon
both from the beatles both from the
beatles wow and michael jackson bought
the beatles music interesting
fun fact but you know a little bit about
the beatles right now they're they're
they're a music in fact on their albums
they do a lot of occult yeah
they had alistair crowley in the in one
of their album covers the sergeant
pepper's band they've uh
had pictures of them doing like a lot of
well they're really intrigued by the
eastern mysticism and the uh what was it
called harry krishna and stuff like that
right and so that's that's interesting
that's all i'm saying at this point
then uh just another interesting fact
the one below him
is also a well-known singer is mariah
carey she writes a lot of her own music
but this guy writes the music for
everybody else is that strange so
check this out 25 uh uh top 100
one hit song or top 100 number one hit
songs
1998 well i'll just read through them
real quick just so you have an idea
because i didn't i didn't just britney
spears but let's let's just look at some
of the songs you might recognize these
some of them i don't so it's gonna be me
in sync i kissed a girl katy perry
so what pink my life would stink without
you kelly carson three britney spears
california girls i'm just gonna read the
titles now teenage dream raise your
glass hold it against me e.t
uh
last friday night part of me one more
night anyway i'm gonna go on and on this
is this is probably uh you've probably
recognized and i've only gotten to 2012.
he's continuing on all the way up to
2022 2023 i'm sure he's continuing i
mean
that's over 25 years over 25 years he's
been this in fact he was he was doing
this with a buddy of his when he buddy
of him pulled pulled him in
and then his buddy died five years into
it and he took over the business
and so anyway anyway
this
kind of shows you this next clip kind of
shows you just how much he is um
involved in this this is uh one of the
one of the boy bands or at least three
of the boy bands i think i forget if
it's in sync or backstreet boys but they
they do a little funny clip for him here
he this guy's from the backstreet boys
max you truly are the heart and soul of
the backstreet boys
tonight we heard a song called as long
as you love me
as one of max's favorites uh wrote the
song produced it he's like hey go sing
this go sing this go sing this
okay
and so we did so
so he
he tells him he tells all these artists
how to sing you know how much control
this guy has yeah um if i'm not mistaken
it was
him and uh katy perry not katy perry
taylor swift
worked very close together and then they
they broke up like musically and it was
because he wouldn't allow her to write
her own songs
really yeah
oh i would need to be fact checked like
to make sure that was the actual reason
and that wasn't rumored but that would
be interesting if he was that
controlling and this is taylor swift for
talking about she's a prolific writer in
the industry she's written for other
people and herself and has had number
ones i find that really interesting for
a couple of reasons because if this guy
is literally getting ideas from a
spiritual source
and he's like no no we're gonna go with
my idea like you can't you can't be in
control of your own idea here
uh that's that's crazy yeah it's almost
like you're just replaceable like oh no
you're gonna sing this song or you'll
just be filled with the next story we've
got some other one coming and you know
they'll do it they really aren't like on
the nsync album cover where they say no
strings attached and they got the
marionettes like that is showing you
that these people are literally puppets
like you don't get to be you
you're
it's gonna be me
it's gonna be somebody else because
that you're just an image you know and
and what's even kind of crazy is like
when you listen to the lyrics i've
always thought this
some of these songs sound like okay they
might be talking about a girlfriend but
they could also be singing this to
whatever god they serve right yeah i
mean it's like this is a
adoration or love song to the devil yeah
and it's interesting to me that he seems
to be such a floater he's not loyal to
one record like record label or anything
like that so
he has influence over a broader set of
people because people listen to
different things but he's also in
different things as well
right right so i dug into this guy a
little bit because i wanted to know
exactly what does he believe where is he
going with all this and does he is he
interested in influencing society
and so he believes that the the key to
producing a puncher is what he said key
to producing a punchier sound was to
wrap it in a greater spiritual
understanding
what does that mean i mean so i don't
know if he's spiritual or not or if he
believes in god or not but he he says
definitely the way to produce a good
quality song is to wrap it in
spirituality
it's interesting how humanity reacts to
that response to that is drawn to that
the spiritual realm
you know it's like i think the reason
why the number one commandment is
worship god and you know it's like
you should have no other gods before you
is because god knows that he designed us
to have this just desire to worship
and it's supposed to be to only worship
him but the devil sees that and he's
perverted that and so it's like this
worship of you know celebrities or
everything is is really tapping into
like our dna
and he also says that that he felt that
this spiritual
meaning
would also help culture so that tells me
and you kind of kind of read between the
lines and what he's saying there but he
that means that he is trying to change
culture a little bit by adding meaning
to the song that you wouldn't otherwise
understand right
and we're going to hear from his own
words uh what that means in a second but
he also said a well-known uh he's well
known for taking the rock and roll riffs
of the past
and bringing them to pop culture using
the soft instruments like the synth
and so he uses these instruments with
the same beats the same riffs that have
been used in in harder so that's why you
see
like the progression of music over time
you know like
i when i go to the grocery store now i
hear music that i never dreamed i would
have heard in the grocery store 20 years
ago it's like wait a minute i used i
used to have that cd and that was kind
of like edgy then now it's what old
people are listening to in the grocery
store you know you're pushing the cart
down target and all of a sudden you're
here and i kissed a girl and it's like
what
is going on
isn't this odd that we listen to these
things in society and nobody questions
that which means
success yeah he wanted to ship's culture
change culture and now people are just
embracing all of this just takes a
generation just a generation just some
time so this guy uh the interesting
thing is that i'm i'm half swedish you
know swedish i can learn that today i
didn't know that i have some swedish uh
background as well my my grandfather was
full blood swedish so you say you know
you speak swedish yeah
what i know right
i lived there near stockholm my junior
year of high school so i learned it cool
that's cool learn something new every
day yeah so this guy
is so well known in music industry that
they fly when they become big they fly
out to sweden to see him it's like the
pope or something dude
and and he uh he because he's such a
well-known producer of these songs and
so he's like and then they fly out and
they're like okay what do you want me to
sing he's like sing this sing this sing
this and you'll do well right wow and
he's like that is like a guru or
something the man behind the curtain
right
yeah so so listen from his own words in
swedish you got to read the the
subtitles but this is what he says ready
sometimes a song becomes more than just
a song
popular
till the last
the interesting thing about this is that
he doesn't have
a swedish accent in english he knows
english pretty well but um he he
definitely has a first language of
swedish and i'm going to come back to
that in a second because that's going to
be important but this is what he said if
you can somehow influence popular
culture shape it in some way when
something becomes bigger than just a
song that's the greatest thing for me
that's the greatest thing so you know a
lot of people think like this is just
music like we hear from kids all the
time why are you guys making a big deal
about this that's that pop song right
look at this these guys are talking
about shaping your ideas shaping culture
they know that they're influencing
people the irony is that the people who
are actually listening to it want to
fight against that and be like it
doesn't affect me and yet every movement
has a slogan every movement has a song
that you can connect it to it's like
part of the foundation yeah yeah
wrapping it
not the only
case we hear this exact thing like i i
can't remember what presentations but we
show presentations all the time where
people are saying
this genre of music this uh genre of
movies shapes and molds cultures i mean
so you have to ask where does this
influence come from where does he where
does he uh getting this idea that he
wants to influence society in this way
he's going to tell us but before we do
it reminds me of of another artist
named carlos santana who was a little
more bold in
telling people exactly what is going on
behind the scenes here he sat me down
and he told me that he had done his
meditations and that he had spoken with
his wife and and that he had spoken with
with the angels and they had come to him
and and they had told him that this is
what he needs to do who's he so santana
carlos santana so a little longer
excerpt of this um that i didn't feel
would be i thought would be caught by
content id so i didn't go too long with
this but basically that was the main
point of what he said he said he would
go to his
his music studio which is separate room
in his house he would sit down he would
do the meditations he would light the
candles he would do his worship
basically to these to these angels
right and the angels would come to him
after a certain period of time after he
had done his worship service and they
would say
write this down
and then they would give him lyrics and
he says i'm just a i'm just a human
facts machine they give me stuff to
write i write it i become popular
someone said that same exact thing was
it a comic book writer yeah there's a
lot of alan moore he
said that too isn't santana uh isn't
that a religion
i know that's santoria santeria okay
like yeah close but like this is
popular this is mainstream in the new
age world people who meditate this is
where a lot of people who are in the new
age now say
you know i didn't try to get into this
this started out when i was doing yoga
and then when i was doing yoga people
were like oh you got to come to the
mindful meditation class so i start
doing that and the next thing you know
you start having
uh
communication with ascended masters yeah
and they come in the form of angels yep
jesus buddha
alien topic right how do they begin to
start to see stuff is through the
meditation so yeah you you're meditating
it's like you've placed yourself on that
ground and you're opening up saying all
right i'm here let's communicate in fact
just today i saw on tick tock i mean
tick tock is a plethora of spiritualism
right now in fact one of the things that
they said on tick duck was hey you know
what you should contact these aliens
just like you said and beings of light
this is what they said beings of light
will come to you
i don't know about a being of light in
the bible
transforms himself as an angel of light
interesting so this is this is all over
the place and so what i think is is uh
the most thing that i think we should
remember is john 4 1. beloved believe
not every spirit but try the spirits
whether they are of god because
many false prophets
are gone out into the world and and
really what is the job of a prophet what
is a prophet really designed to do
the messenger right
who he's giving you a message delivered
from the spiritual world right i mean
look at these guys they are literally
prophets of
are they promoting you know wholesome
living
good relationships or is it like yeah
just hit me one more time baby
and you know what's interesting like no
christian i really hope this is like no
christian should ever say oh it's just
music oh it's just a show it's not gonna
really do anything because that's
discounting your own religion your own
faith we believe that we pray to god and
he responds he acts there's miracles he
answers our prayers and we also know the
counter to that is the devil so to say
that
it doesn't work when people try to
contact the devil it's like does it work
when we contact god and
i think that's an excellent point and
and one step further from that is like
the only experiences that we know or
we've heard in the bible where music was
used in a way of pushing the devil away
was david when saul was ready to like
kill him and he was angry and all of a
sudden david was just playing music and
the spirits left saul
so
it's not just the lyrics and everything
together it's the whole
kitten caboodle is
it's allowing the spiritual you know
beings to interact with us and that's
where i was kind of going when i found
that he was using the old rock and roll
riffs yeah i don't know how it works
together i don't know what works with it
but i i know that he was using the old
rock and roll riffs to influence society
through pop culture i bet if you could
go back in time and sit and listen to a
babylonian worship ceremony or something
i guarantee you'd be like that sounds
like kanye
[Laughter]
in in stores they will actually play a
certain type of music and maybe this is
why we hear pop music in a store that
certain types of rhythms and stuff start
to make you feel like yeah i feel good
yeah
or whatever you know like they're
they're actually methodical with even
what type of music they play in that
store yeah that's what that's technology
physiology it's all yeah you zach and
they've put
i've heard that they at least used to
put subliminal messages in there like
don't steal buy more
but what you said like okay so if music
really does shape the culture and change
people and
the different beats make people do
different things then what's happening
when
rock and roll rebellious rifts are now
entering into the pop world and that's
what's playing on the radio can we look
at statistics and see like shoplifting
is
more increased than it was 10 years ago
or something you know like what's
happening to people when they're in
public hearing this music does a certain
genre come to mind when you look at
different time periods 80s
yeah 70s yeah 60s and then that does
that correlate to what was happening in
the culture at that time yeah elvis in
the 50s yeah yeah a little bit yeah i
mean you could see like in the 70s you
know there was a lot of like disco yeah
and like
yeah 60s and just people's compariment
and how it matched with the music yeah
so i went further into this and i
thought you know what i need to find out
how he makes this music because if
santana says that he's making it through
a fax machine basically a human facts
machine coming and talking with the
angels i can't believe he called them
angels i think that's that blows my mind
but uh let's see what this guy says
because i think he's a little more
subtle in how he approaches it this is
what he said can you tell us about
making this song i was going to bed and
this melody of the the chorus sort of
started you know
coming in
but i was really tired and uh i was
lying there
uh
trying to
motivate myself to get out of bed and
record this thing because i had a
feeling it was good and i recorded it
and then i say
hit like baby one more time
and i was like and then i hear myself
say yeah that's pretty good this record
baby one more time by the great britney
spears was actually number one in every
single country on the planet it was
released so not only is he uh receiving
the lyrics but he's also providing the
melody the whole kitten caboodle i mean
everything from hey an artist would
often say
the thing i learned the most by working
with this guy is it's how i'm
pronouncing the words and how i'm
putting the words in the different
syllables in certain places and so he's
not only saying hey i want you to sing
it this tone i want you to sing it with
these lyrics but he's also saying
this is how i want you to say it so he
for what i think is happening here he
hears it in his head okay can i can i
just like blow your mind for a second do
you know what baby hit me one more time
says backwards
no
sleep with me i'm not too young
i'm dead serious
like dead seriously
[Music]
so that's interesting to me
very specific with you need to hit this
syllable on this thing because when you
hear it backwards it is like sleep with
me i'm not too young i mean it's that
plane yeah like back masking is a is a
weird thing because if you say it
differently it doesn't sound the same it
has to be said a certain way and then
it's like well what is the meaning of
hit me baby one more time why is this a
hook that's repeated over and over what
does it even mean yeah hit me baby one
more time what i think is interesting is
that he is making the songs for these
people sorry
i think it's interesting is
these artists don't get to write their
own music
and in the beginning
they have to be trained it's almost like
they're being trained like this is how
you write music you're going to say it
this way you're going gonna you know he
said that he said use less words and
make it simpler and then it's like okay
now you're ready now you can make you've
been well trained that now you're gonna
make music the way that i've taught you
to now it's on to somebody else i'm
gonna train them and they're going to
keep
making sense
disciples wow literally wow wow and the
angels are teaching this guy so
literally he's a false prophet who's
teaching disciples and that's why i
think it's it's
it's really like if you think of how
satan's warfare is against us right
he's he he could spend his time trying
to get every single one of us to like
you know buy into his lies or he makes
somebody like this that has this mass
influence all he's got to do is
manipulate that one guy a false prophet
yeah and then it's like he's working
with this one guy and he knows what that
one guy's going to put out there and
it's this consistent plan i mean it's
kind of like how the military works
right you work through the general and
he tells the people what to do and you
know and it's the exact opposite how god
wanted it god's like you know what
spread out i want a tower of babel
everyone everyone dispersed because if
you do
continue to stay together you can do
almost anything it's it's going to be a
sinful it's going to be terrible
god wants us to live away from the
cities he wants us to be sectioned off
in different areas so that we aren't as
influenced as fast by the by the culture
around us and so i think
everything everything in the bible
points to that that same way of thinking
where you aren't from a top down
uh way of thinking
but i started looking into the symbolism
here because i think uh the symbols even
though i don't like to uh
dive too far into symbolism because
i mean even just today i got a comment
that said well we we don't trust you in
your documentary because you had held
your hands together the wrong way come
on
come on guys yeah but i think that um
it's interesting when you get tattoos of
certain symbols on your arm permanently
that's a little more purposeful than i
did a hand gesture or something right
putting your hand wrong you know things
like that that that can be accidental
that can be not accidental right i woke
up with this what's it mean so so the
bible says in psalms 101 3 i set no
wicked thing before mine eyes i hate the
work of them that turn aside it shall
not cleave to me
and so
not only is he's writing the song lyrics
he's writing the music to it but he's
also giving them symbolism because the
people that he works with and we're
going to see this just in a second uh
have these symbolisms as a part of their
religion let me show you real quick just
some of the symbology inside the the
music
[Music]
boy you should know what you're falling
for
baby do you dare to do this
[Music]
you see all the symbology as uh from i
mean just
just the ancient egypt symbology in this
i mean there's no question that's where
they were going
and if you look at the the new age
movement if you look at the ufo movement
if you look at all this this this
culture that's happening that's kind of
coming together right now it all ties
back to the sumerians the egyptians and
the back of our dollar bill
bro why is there a pyramid for the
united states of america it doesn't even
make sense why is there a pyramid for
the new space force why is there an
egyptian um uh that sphinx
on the on the logo for the space force
what is that all about has nothing to do
with america yeah except for isn't isn't
the symbol of egypt in the bible
basically like you know who is god that
i should listen to him isn't that why
the bible describes that in in
revelation it's like who's your god when
pharaoh said that to to moses yeah yeah
egypt's always a symbol in the bible of
like a rebellious nation right
so i'm just going to go over a couple
pictures here uh they a constant use of
the horse
what is this called centaur the centaur
when you have the half human half horse
thingy or um or minotaur which i don't
know we might want to get that right
it's it's interesting because
what does this have to do with music
what does this have to do with the song
why why is the constant use of of the
the horse in here yeah and now
what is going on on her shirt and on the
leg of the horse what is that egyptian
conk yeah that song's even called dark
horse when you think about revelation
there's uh so what does the ankh really
represent in any
in this so there's a lot of stuff about
the ankh and it they say uh it like so i
did a little research on this because i
i was like why is this in every single
song that i see from max martin
practically i mean it's in everything an
ankh uh the top part represents they say
represents the woman the bottom part
represents the man and it's a it's a uh
a sign of fertility and they said that's
part of it but it's also a sign of god
they said this is a sign of i am um a
god i know so it's so so once again it's
like you know egypt basically saying you
know like who's your god like and the
new age says whatever
yeah whoever holds it i mean she's got
it on her body she's saying i'm gone and
don't you find it kind of interesting
that it's like almost in the shape of a
cross oh yeah you know like
that's like almost like the devil
foresaw
i don't know well satan is a deceiver he
wants to be real close to the truth my
dad said when he was a teenager he
liked this symbol because he thought it
was like the cross he started seeing
artists you know uh celebrities wearing
it and thought oh that's pretty cool
yeah i kind of want to get one of those
necklaces because it looks like a cross
yeah remember that one that one music
video that kanye made that was all in
slow motion it was like all egypt stuff
yeah yeah it's all over so um this
symbol right here
is also on um
yeah ace of base oh my goodness yeah the
ace of base song that was also max
martin song by the way wow i saw the
signs what was the sign the sign was the
yonk donk yeah and and so he slowly
switched over from the ankh into this
horse-like uh figure i forget what it's
called maybe someone in the comments can
tell us exactly what that thing is but
that's kind of been merging over that
area this is one of his his helpers in
his uh in his his community what is on
his arm in the orc the yonk
why did he tattoo the ankh on his arm i
have no idea why you would want to do
that
but
this is again symbolism doesn't say
anything except
hey maybe this is um just interesting
i want to go back to
one of max martin's songs made by the
backstreet boys uh and just listen to
the lyrics real quick i want to see what
what you think about this
you'll recognize this song if you've
ever been in home depot or walmart or
anything i have no place to go
[Music]
surrender your heart body and soul to
who
like you said some of these songs are
like is it a love song is it a song to a
god what is that i'm telling you you
could take a lot of this stuff and you
could apply it to god
or you could apply it to a fault god you
know it's like that's not necessarily
just about a woman or something you know
right i hope not i mean
and if you look in the lyrics here see i
we we do a lot of renovations my wife
and i and and one of the
one of the albums i'll let her listen to
is is her backstreet albums because it's
more we're married and uh it's it's more
of a
worship album it seems to a girlfriend a
boyfriend so i don't feel it affects me
as much as some of the other music that
they have out there but um
this one in particular bothers me
whenever i have time i hear it because
it has a lot to do with your body your
soul and i have no idea what it's saying
it's too close to like the what the
bible describes you know it's like you
know we should love god with our with
all of our heart mind and soul and you
know
so i dug into it i was like max max
martin what in the world are you
thinking when that was this song yeah
yeah like every single backstreet boys
song is this is an insane nsync and
backstreet were done by the same
producer they pitted them against each
other and then max martin wrote a lot of
their songs that's funny dude they made
this rivalry and this one dude writing
it right yeah but they always seem to do
hollywood does this often it'll make two
movies like a war movie comes out and
there's like always two movies and stuff
and i wonder if they feel like if
there's a little bit of competition
they'll try to like you know do better
or outdo each other or something like
that you know and maybe it gets their
thing more noticed or seen i don't know
competition is the devil's uh way to to
address this uh the the problem of doing
things well
love
is the way god does things if you love
someone or if you love to do something
you'll do your very best at it yeah yeah
i have a question i'm kind of stuck on
on that song about the the
body and soul
what do you think the problem is with
metaphors
what's wrong with if i asked my husband
hey give me i want your soul like i'll
give you i'll give you my soul i
understand it sounds creepy bro
like the metaphors that we use
especially in love songs what do you
think the issue would be
for christians i mean i think certainly
you can worship your spouse uh you know
i'm sure there's there's situations
where people probably that's their
that's their main key of affection where
i i see a relationship should should
incorporate god you know and god should
should be the one that
that deserves your worship i don't
necessarily i don't know if
i would describe it as worshiping my
spouse you know you should have no other
gods before me i mean
yeah so i i would say that would be kind
of the main thing if of you know just
the way that that was presented seemed
more like a worship situation then
okay and that's baby yeah you went in
the direction i thought you would like
we're christians everything that we do
there's a verse whatsoever you do do
alter the glory of god god should be
your focus you should be your number one
even above your spouse certain things or
for him yeah and then he allows so much
variety and so much other things for us
to enjoy amongst ourselves but certain
things are for him so we should keep
that in mind as we listen to things as
we watch things as we partake in things
yeah
i think there's a uh uh frank sinatra
one that that that i remember hearing
and he talked about you know you're all
that i worship and i adore and i was
just always that always bothered me
whenever i heard that and i was just
like well that just that's just not true
yeah it's just against the bible has had
one too it's like you're my
you're the light in my darkness and
you're my savior when i fall and all
this
it's like to a woman though
so interesting fact uh frank natura
didn't he'd write the one i i'll do it
my way so uh the satanic bible was
inspired after the work of aleister
crowley yeah right and aleister crowley
said that this was the most satanic song
of its of its time so i added the words
uh this this is the song that you just
heard show me the meaning of being
lonely i think it's interesting because
um max martin i said i was looking up
how did he come up these words well he's
like well you know i don't really speak
uh english that well and so i just kind
of match up different words together
that sound like they have good syllables
so if you read this song it doesn't
sound like it makes a lot of sense but
you can make a lot of different ideas
from it and so people are like well
maybe it's about his his lover maybe
it's about worshiping me let me just
read this to you real quick
life goes on as it never ends
eyes of stone observe the trends
they never say be forever gays if only
guilty roads to an endless love
there's no control are you with me now
um
your every wish will be done that what
every wish will be that reminds me of
aladdin right
you know what i mean so i will show you
the world everything you want
they tell me there's nowhere to run i i
have no place to go surrender your heart
body and soul
can i can i just point something out
about that that your your your every
wishes will be done um you know the
bible does talk about if we ask in the
father's name that it will be given to
us right
as well but name exactly a name in the
bible is synonymous with character if
it's done and asked in the character
that god would
deliver something like that it'll be
done for you because it's within god's
will right like you said that is not
within
you know that means whatever i want
whatever i desire no matter if it's
going to destroy me and i want it you're
going to give it to me
we're
kind of
alluding to the fact that he's getting
these lyrics from the demonic world
and if satan wants to give you his
message i mean he's literally saying
uh
there's no place to run he's like he's
saying i'll give you all your wishes
yeah what did he do with jesus hey bow
to me i'll give you all the kingdoms of
the world and he's saying just give me
your mind body and soul just sad because
he still thinks he has the power right
but the keys were given up at the cross
right
it's christ that controls this world
that's true
and so i have a few more examples of the
strangeness that's in max martin's songs
because this is this is not just
again he's not just providing the
the music he's also providing the
symbology hey this is this will be good
with this this will be good with this
what what's going on here you're so
hypnotizing could you be the devil could
you be an angel
i that's the same thing i think that's
interesting but
you're from a whole another world a
different dimension open your eyes and
i'm ready to go lead me into the light
boy you're an alien you're torch you're
so foreign it's supernatural extra
terrestrial yeah dude i always when that
song came out i was not in any sort of
christian frame of mind
and i remember looking at that going
man
that's demonic like like and i wasn't
even like close to
it's so catchy it sounds so good but
she's literally talking about
having relations with an alien or
something yeah someone came up to me and
they're like this is this talking about
uh relations with the devil what what is
she talking about here yeah dude every
song is the same this is aladdin i can
open it so max wrote this yeah whoa bro
yeah
you're
are you the devil are you an angel
you're hypnotizing me
uh you can open my eyes dude this is
literally satan in the garden so so i
wonder i wonder this and and
you know this question comes up a lot
people go well is there some sort of
conspiracy where they're sitting down
and being like okay how can i like
deceive the christians and this and that
right
um i really wonder like is he getting
these ideas and not aware of where he's
getting them
are these thoughts coming to him like
he's thinking like oh yeah like i had
this really great idea and i heard this
lyric when i went to bed i mean he's
meditating he said he was and and and
doing things that would invite this kind
of a uh uh
downloading if you would um
but i wonder you know if it what what a
dismissal you know if it's just like no
i just came up with these cool sounding
lyrics but we read this in the christian
mind frame and we're like no this is
like super like he's talking about the
devil straight up yeah that's the thing
i don't think they have anything to
compare it to because they're not in the
word so they're just like oh this sounds
kind of cool you know open my eyes and
are you an angel and hypnotizing me
so they're not they don't have the
biblical lenses that we do they're just
thinking and they probably it's probably
one of two things
some of them probably just think
oh that was my own thoughts that was my
own idea that just came to me out of
nowhere but really it was influenced or
they think wow these supernatural beings
are giving me really cool music but
they're not thinking anything sinister
about it they're just thinking
i'm communicating with other
beings out there and it's really cool
you know that's the new age is all about
that
you say they don't know the bible but
you know who does
satan that's right you know and we as
christians we should know it quite well
as well in the end times angels will
come i mean the devil presents himself
um as different not just the angel of
light
but comes to deceive and he takes the
form of humans and he interacts with us
something to be aware of i was just
listening to you hear those lyrics and i
was like that could very well be true
you know we're supposed to um
not only test the spirits but we'll know
them by their fruits and if you're
looking at someone and they're
exhibiting certain qualities you should
ask yourself is this someone who's an
ally who is a follower of christ or are
they on the other side are you a demon
or are you an angel these are questions
that we should be asking but
maybe not in the context of this song
but in day-to-day life and to kind of
springboard off of what you just said
remember when jesus was sitting there
talking to peter and he said you know
get the behind me satan right he's
talking to peter
and peter's reacting like satan would
and trying to inspire him with doing
something different and you know you
don't you're not you don't have to go to
the cross so yeah it's very possible
that we could be used
by the devil and we don't even realize
it could be in the positive too was it
joshua who was talking to uh when the
angel left he realized he was talking to
a heavenly being abraham and the two
guests i mean it can go either way we
just need to be mindful we need to be
discerning
a lot of people i've heard a lot of
people say in christendom well once you
are with christ once you are saved once
you are uh
have that relationship with god you
can't be
you can't be you can't have be connected
with the the spiritual realm
so you can't be inhabited by these demon
spirits you can't be i mean all this all
this stuff
you know we are vessels if we allow that
stuff into our life it will come in
that's right no matter if you're
professing god or not you you you can
become that thing that you don't want to
happen i mean that was saul right saul
didn't and immediately was like hey you
know i'm going to become a terrible king
no he became over time
something that he wished he wasn't oh
even nebuchadnezzar became a believer
after he threw the three hebrews in and
and saw that they weren't consumed but
then years down the road he's like look
at this kingdom that i made and
and they became a beast for seven years
that's demonic possession if anything
and so that's my presentation i think
that's really interesting what we've
covered today and i think that our the
bible we need to be in the bible reading
the bible because we won't be able to
see the deception coming upon us unless
we are in the bible every day doing the
three things that every christian should
do praying sharing and reading the word
amen
and if it speaks not according to the
word like those these these things that
we're listening to should be in
consistency with the bible the the the
the thing that that is interesting about
music is it's your emotions and the
theology that's attached those two
things are why we like it you know like
one makes us feel a certain way and then
it puts those words in our minds and
and so you know if these things are are
opposite of what the bible would kind of
teach you then it's not a good idea to
listen to this kind of stuff
so i want to throw the question to you
have you heard of any songs like this in
the past we are doing a documentary on
music right now and we want your help
because we don't listen to a lot of this
stuff and we want to know what is it
that you've heard in the past we don't
want you to go out and seek it but at
that same time before you had
accepted this message what is it that
you who had heard and said wow that is
is not in line with the bible send us
some of your uh your uh title send us
some of your uh lyrics we were curious
and we were gonna check into it and deep
deep dive into it and find this stuff
out thank you so much for watching likes
are very free and comments are very free
please leave us a lot of those because
it helps the algorithm and we look
forward to seeing you next week
[Music]
hi you might not know me because i work
mostly behind the scenes
but my name is michael and i'm the
director of little light studios 3d
department
right now we're experimenting with new
technology
where we're trying to blend reality with
the virtual world it's more efficient
and offer us the opportunity to make
higher quality productions with better
visuals
by using the unreal engine software it
gives us the possibility to create
realistic virtual environments for sets
in a short amount of time
we are working with what we have because
we do have financial limits
that's why we're working toward getting
an led wall in the future because it
will allow us to use extended reality
this simply means that we don't need
green screen anymore
it will save us tremendous time in the
post compositing process
we will also have realistic accurate
lighting that comes from led wall
which matches the subject and the set in
real time
actors are able to see the set rather
than having to imagine the scenes within
the confines of the green screen
[Music]
so that's what we've been up to here at
little eye studios
we're so thankful for the ways that god
has blessed us
and we're so excited for what he has for
us in the future
[Music]
you